>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Matthew Barton: Hi, my
name is Matthew Barton.
I am the Curator of Recorded
Sound at the Library of Congress.
It is a wonderful job,
and I have to do it.
Most of the time I am
down at the Packard Campus
for Audiovisual Conservation
in Culpepper, Virginia,
about 70 miles southwest of here
on the way to Charlottesville.
And once upon a time, though,
I did work in this building.
I can't really see you now,
but there's probably somebody
out there I used to work with.
And in the Packard Campus for
Audiovisual Conservation --
it's a mouthful, sorry
-- there are three --
approximately 3 1/2
million sound recordings.
That's not every sound
recording that's ever been,
and obviously there are
millions more yet to be made.
However, we're always
filling in gaps.
But today when I pulled together
the display you saw outside,
I was very pleased to find
that we had every Firesign
Theater album and every solo album.
[ Applause ]
So obviously, my predecessors
were doing something right.
And one of those albums,
"Don't Crush that Dwarf,
Hand Me the Pliers," in 2005
was added to the Library
of Congress' National
Recording Registry.
[ Applause ]
I think at that time
there was only a couple
of hundred other items
on the registry.
We're now closing in on 500, but
it's still a very select group
of recordings that are
historically, aesthetically,
and technically significant,
exceptional, lasting,
as the Firesign Theater is.
And I don't want to go on too long,
because I know why you're here.
So I think I'll just cut to the
chase and say thank you so much
for joining us here at
the Library of Congress.
If it's your first time, I hope
it's the first of many times.
I hope all of you come back.
It's really a wonderful place,
and it is here for you to use --
for all Americans to use.
So with that, I will just say
that it's an honor for me to stand
on this stage and introduce to you
two of the four or five crazy guys,
the Firesign Theater --
or what's left of it --
Phil Proctor and David Ossman.
[ Applause ]
>> David Ossman: Thank you.
My goodness.
Well, here we are.
And the first line
is yours, as usual.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh!
Thank you.
>> David Ossman: There it is.
That's good.
>> Phil Proctor: Tonight
the Firesign Theater --
>> David Ossman: Or
what's left of it.
>> Phil Proctor: I,
the other Phil --
>> David Ossman: --
and I, the only Dave,
are here to prove once
and for all that --
>> D and Phil Proctor: --
everything you know is wrong --
>> David Ossman: -- about
the history of radio.
Yes.
>> Phil Proctor: Thank you, Dave.
>> David Ossman: Yes,
you're welcome.
>> Phil Proctor: According
to the most recently DOA-approved
schoolbooks, we've been told
that the very first wireless
transmission was invented
by Spaghettini [assumed
spelling], the clicker macaroni,
in the obscure Italian town of
Pizo Electrico [assumed spelling].
>> David Ossman: But --
but -- but no, not so.
No, no.
>> Phil Proctor: Que?
>> David Ossman: Well,
at least not according
to Professor Pierre
Savat [assumed spelling]
of the Vondanican [assumed
spelling] Institute of --
copies available in the lobby.
But let him speak for himself.
>> Phil Proctor: Thank you.
>> David Ossman: And welcome.
>> Phil Proctor: In my latest book,
"Hubcaps of the Gods," available
in airports everywhere,
I have conclusively
demonstrated indubitably --
>> David Ossman: That's
without a doobie [laughter].
>> Phil Proctor: -- that the first
truly wireless society was the
dreary druids of India.
I personally participated in the
hitherto secret evacuation team.
>> David Ossman: Well,
it's not secret anymore.
It's available online,
like everything else.
>> Phil Proctor: Who unearthed an
early recycling center on the Plain
of Bell Jars near Plath --
>> David Ossman: Very close.
>> Phil Proctor: -- containing piles
of primitive batteries rusting,
undisturbed, for the
last 200,000 years?
>> David Ossman: Golly,
that's longer than anybody
has been gone before.
>> Phil Proctor: Yes.
>> David Ossman: Yes -- yes.
>> Phil Proctor: And amidst
the myriad aterfacts [sic] --
or archticfacts [sic]
uncovered, replicas of which --
ancient batteries not included --
are for sale as you
exit the lobby --
>> David Ossman: Right there.
>> Phil Proctor: -- our team
found not one scrap, trace,
shred, or fragment of wires.
>> David Ossman: No.
>> Phil Proctor: Thus
proving, inconsequentially,
that prehistrionic
Italy -- or India --
>> David Ossman: Or both.
>> Phil Proctor: -- was
indeed -- or both --
the origin of the first
totally wireless society.
>> David Ossman: Boy
-- well, thank you,
Professor Savat for
whatever that was.
>> Phil Proctor: Buy the book.
>> David Ossman: Yes, buy the book.
Well, how ironic it is
that this discovery,
like so many other ancient
revelations should be delayed
for so many centuries.
Kind of like our checks in the mail.
>> Phil Proctor: Right,
I remember that.
>> David Ossman: And forcing us
as primitive Americans
to invent the wire.
>> Phil Proctor: Somebody --
>> David Ossman: Somebody.
>> Phil Proctor: -- had to do it.
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
somebody had to do it.
>> Phil Proctor: That's right.
>> David Ossman: For sure.
>> Phil Proctor: Or is it --
>> David Ossman: Otherwise --
[ Mumbling ]
July 12th, 1843, Washington, AC/DC.
Another insufferably
undrained, swampy day.
In the stifling Supreme
Court chambers.
And a wire [sic] we here?
Aha, because we are tirelessly,
but not yet wirelessly,
awaiting the first transmission
for the calloused fingers
of Samuel F.B. Morose, an
inventor so poor he had to wait
until night rates applied before
sending his first historic
first message.
>> Phil Proctor: Gentlemen
[clearing throat],
gentlemen, your attention, please.
As your Cheap Justice, I declare
that the so-called telegraphic
message should be coming
through any minute now.
And here it is!
[ Telegraph Beeping Sounds ]
Ah, cracky, that's great.
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
it's my [inaudible].
It's wonderful.
>> Phil Proctor: Yes, please.
Go ahead.
>> David Ossman: Shall I take it?
>> Phil Proctor: Yes.
>> David Ossman: All
right, thank you.
By cracky, Mr. Cheap
-- I love this voice.
I got to do it.
>> Phil Proctor: And it's your only
voice, isn't it, as far as I know?
>> David Ossman: It's the
only one I have for this --
>> Phil Proctor: I've
heard that voice before.
>> David Ossman: Yes,
we borrowed it.
>> Phil Proctor: Fifty
years of that voice.
>> David Ossman: Yeah
[blowing raspberry].
>> Phil Proctor: Hell, you
were born with that voice.
Oh, well, carry on.
>> David Ossman: Let's
go back to the script.
Oh, by cracky, Mr.
Cheap Justice, sir --
there's a country [inaudible]
-- well, let me see.
Well, that come through
a clear as a bell jar.
You were waiting for that.
>> Phil Proctor: So
what does it say?
>> David Ossman: Well,
let me see here.
Let me see, let me see, let me see.
It says dit, dit-dit, dit,
dit-dit-dit, da, da, da.
Dit-dit-dit --
>> Phil Proctor: TMI.
>> David Ossman: --
dit-dit-dit, da, da --
>> Phil Proctor: TMI.
>> David Ossman: Oh!
>> Phil Proctor: TMI!
>> David Ossman: Oh, excuse
me, Mr. Cheap Justice,
could you perhaps interpret
this historic message for us?
>> Phil Proctor: Well,
of course, I could.
>> David Ossman: Yes, well --
>> Phil Proctor: That's my job.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: I'm
well-paid by you
to spend entire sweaty days
interpreting indecipherable crap
like this.
>> David Ossman: Aye, sure --
>> Phil Proctor: Now let's
see, I think it's some sort
of a street slang, you know,
a [inaudible], a sort
of a bell jargon.
Oh, dash it all, this is tough.
I just have to say
it's about dis and dot!
>> David Ossman: Well, it was.
It was indeed about dis and dot.
And just what did dis dot wrought?
It wrought the next step
on the path of progress!
>> Phil Proctor: Hello, inventor
of the phone company,
Alexander Bell Jar here.
Oh, it's Mr. Watson, I presume?
>> David Ossman: Yes.
>> Phil Proctor: What
can I do for you?
>> David Ossman: I -- I've stumbled
across the most frightful
conspiracy.
It's a plot -- a plot to ensnare
the world in wires and poles,
to fill the homes of the poor with
ringing noises, to allow naked men
to talk to naked women
without them knowing it.
And worst of all, to
charge great sums
of money while cutting off service
to pathetic pensioners
while they bake or freeze
to death in their own homes.
Holmes! Do you hear me, Holmes?
>> Phil Proctor: I'm
horrendously sorry, old fellow,
but you've got the wrong number.
>> David Ossman: Oh!
[Dial tone sounding] Well,
while naked people all
over the world paired up
to talk to one another,
the brilliant German scientist
Heinrich Megahertz, alone,
on his own, in his home in Cologne,
was sniffing the all-pervasive
ether, and he had a vision,
[bell ringing] a strange vision.
A vision of electric waves
undulating along limpid,
invisible molecular
highways, oscillating,
shimmering, electromagnetic fields.
But he also saw dragons,
little guys in melty hats,
and the last three episodes
of "Time Out for Beaver."
>> Phil Proctor: Soon news of his
discovery spread far and wide,
and the images of surfing
on undulating electromagnetic
waves had a peculiar appeal --
>> David Ossman: Oh, to
the Beach Boys, sure.
>> Phil Proctor: Good vibrations.
>> David Ossman: Ha ha.
>> Phil Proctor: Right.
And also to a sandy-haired Yaley
[assumed spelling] named Tree
D'Forest, which would
lead him to really suck it
up when he invented
the vacuum cleaner.
>> David Ossman: Phil, Phil.
D'Forest invented the
tube -- the vacuum tube.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, perhaps.
Or was it the tube-powered
vacuum cleaner?
>> David Ossman: Well.
>> Phil Proctor: You can
see the infomercials.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: Anyway, he knew
what it was and what to do with it.
>> David Ossman: And not a moment
too soon, because we needed it
to light up a sign that said --
>> D and Phil Proctor: On the air!
>> David Ossman: [Static
sounds] Hello, America.
This is Jenson Lee, the
honey-sweet voice of station CWKW
in Shraptalese [assumed
spelling], New Jersey.
From [inaudible] studio
on the [inaudible] floor
of O'Raley's [assumed spelling]
Hardware, at the intersection
of Darwin and Strewat
[assumed spelling],
we bring you the tender
tenors of the Bell Jar Boys --
>> Phil Proctor: When
Irish eyes are smiling,
sure, it is like a balmy day.
And when Irish bombs are blasting,
it will blow your pub [bomb falling]
awake, awake, awake, awake --
>> David Ossman: And so
America was on the air.
But there was only one
problem, you see with --
>> Phil Proctor: The bomb.
>> David Ossman: -- being on the
air, once you're on the radio,
you know, you're -- you got stay on.
>> Phil Proctor: And on.
>> David Ossman: And on, and on,
you know, hour after hour and day
after day, week after week, month
after month, year after year,
decade after decade [crying].
>> Phil Proctor: Dave, it's okay.
>> David Ossman: What?
>> Phil Proctor: It's okay, Dave.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, well, but
don't you see, it was all lies.
>> Phil Proctor: What?
Lies? What -- what?
>> David Ossman: No, I meant
live -- it was all live.
>> Phil Proctor: Live
-- it was live!
>> David Ossman: It was all
on the air live, yeah, yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: Right, right.
>> David Ossman: That's right.
>> Phil Proctor: No, Dave.
I think you meant lies.
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
I did, actually.
Well, maybe.
But back then there was no such
thing as a leak or fake news.
>> Phil Proctor: No, no.
>> David Ossman: Not
even a fake President.
What can you do?
[ Applause ]
You're on, Mr. Roosevelt.
>> Phil Proctor: Good
evening, my fellow Americans.
Before I read to you from the funny
papers on our evening fireside chat,
let me make one thing
perfectly clear --
I didn't know Roosevelt
was from the South.
>> David Ossman: Well,
it's a new voice for you.
I understand.
>> Phil Proctor: Let me make
one thing perfectly clear.
>> David Ossman: Clear.
There we go.
>> Phil Proctor: All
we have to fear is me!
>> David Ossman: We interrupt
this socialistic screed --
>> Phil Proctor: Things
haven't changed, have they?
>> David Ossman: -- for
an important broadcast.
Live from the Pisgarten [assumed
spelling] Olympic Auditorium
in Forsample [assumed spelling],
Bavaria, we present a live broadcast
of the Herring-Schmelling
[assumed spelling] --
>> Phil Proctor: I'm in back
of this great, giant auditorium
where the great, big white
man, Herring, and the great,
big black man, Schmelling, are
trading a tremendous series
of punches [static sounds].
Well, it's a lot easier to see
the white man than the black man,
but now the white man, pummeled
by the black man's smoking ham-like
fists, is turning red as a beet,
illuminated by the flickering
glow of tiki torches waved
by his all-white supporters,
some of whom I assume are
good people [crowd sounds].
Oh! And Herring's down!
>> David Ossman: He's down!
>> Phil Proctor: The white man is
down, and the brown shirts are up,
embracing the black man in a kind
of a beer hug, and lifting him
into the air, they throw
him out of the ring!
And now they're propping up the
white man, lifting up his arm.
And yes, it looks like the bloody
red Herring has been declared the
unconscious new world champion!
What an upset!
>> David Ossman: [Static
sounds] And now we take you
to the Naval Gasbag Landing Field
in Lakehurts [assumed
spelling], New Jersey.
It's 1937, and we're taking
you there because we can.
[Wind blowing] I can see the
great ship Hindenburg now,
the majestic hulk, hovering
here over the mooring pylon.
And there's still a
hint of rain in the air.
Uh-oh, uh-oh!
The wind seems to be coming up a
bit, and there's the ground crew
like ants running out
to man the ropes.
And the huge ship is only
about 100 feet overhead,
and I can see tiny people
waving through the windows.
Oh, wait a minute!
Oh, my God!
The ship is heaving
over to the left.
There's a big gust of wind.
There's a spark there
-- and it rights itself,
and it's come around now.
And oh, the last of the
ropes are being secured.
Wow, here come the passengers.
There's Judge Crater.
And look, Amelia Earhart,
there she is.
Jimmy Hoffa, how about that?
Well, a few of the other
passengers, you know, goose-stepping
to get the circulation
back in their legs
after that long trans-Atlantic
flight,
but that is the story
her from Lakehurts.
[ Applause ]
>> Phil Proctor: Yes, yes,
the news may have kept America
on their seats, but it
was the art of radio
that really glued them down.
Simple-minded but addictive
radio series that led to decades
of addictive television in the
years to come, shows like --
>> David Ossman: Is It a Hit
[hands slapping] or a Miss?
>> Phil Proctor: What?
>> David Ossman: Yes, yes, yes.
The makers of Luke's Blood present
the Aboriginal Amateur Hour,
and here's your menial host
Major Arcana [assumed spelling].
>> Phil Proctor: Round
and round I go.
Hey, hey, babe.
We're on the wheel again.
But first, here is a word for you
poor sufferers of blood sludge,
from the wealthy folks at Dremel.
End of song.
>> David Ossman: End of song, the
timeless story of the little people,
striving to make a pie pond
of tranquility in a dirty,
backstabbing, self-conscious hamlet
that accepts neither,
but rejects both.
Brought to you every day by Brie.
>> Phil Proctor: Brie, Brie, Brie!
Clean, clean, clean!
>> David Ossman: Cleaner
than anything.
>> Phil Proctor: End of song!
>> David Ossman: As
you remember, Cookie,
ejected from Dr. Dog's Insane
Asylum, had just been driven
out to the scene of the
fire in Aubrey's stolen car.
Only a few minutes
before, the carrots
and the squirrels had
formed a committee
to flood the Mixville Breadworks
before nightfall [inaudible] court,
nor avoids to unlock
the pent-up riddle
of Blessed Father Urpo [assumed
spelling] before we all reach --
>> Phil Proctor: -- the end of so --
>> David Ossman: Dit-dit,
dit, dit-dit, dit, dit --
>> Phil Proctor: Headquarters,
headquarters, moon 40 Taurus.
>> David Ossman: Roger.
>> Phil Proctor: Sun 29 Pisces.
>> David Ossman: Roger, Roger.
>> Phil Proctor: What?
>> David Ossman: This
one looks serious, Roger.
Cancer is rising.
We'd better call --
>> Phil Proctor: Captain Equifax!
>> David Ossman: Yes!
Captain Equifax, the
deadliest foe of those
who would test our island democracy.
By day, Adolph Tree, a
mild-mannered college professor.
But by night, KiKi, a
mini-skirted [inaudible]
of Hollywood's star-struck
Sunset Strip.
But twice a year, he's --
>> D and Phil Proctor:
Captain Equifax!
>> David Ossman: Today's dumb
story, Spies Over Broadway.
But first --
>> Phil Proctor: [Siren
blaring] Police State.
>> David Ossman: Police State.
>> Phil Proctor: Police State.
>> David Ossman: Help!
It's the police!
>> Phil Proctor: Police
men, real police men.
Its policemen will become --
>> David Ossman: Who's number one?
>> Phil Proctor: -- peace men.
Yes, we're peace men,
even though we wear a gun.
>> D and Phil Proctor:
It's all in fun.
>> David Ossman: Yes, Police State,
where green rookies become
hardened men in blue,
where danger earns a diploma,
and crime gets taught a
civil lesson it deserves.
Listen now as the Federal Bureau
of Marijuana, in cooperation
with Crime Lord magazine,
presents Challenge Number 13,
Roach Patrol on Police State.
>> Phil Proctor: [Laughter]
Do pigs live in trees?
>> David Ossman: Do
pigs live in trees?
>> Phil Proctor: What?
>> David Ossman: If --
>> Phil Proctor: Oh.
If you lived where I live,
and I lived where you lived,
then we'd live where
pigs live, in trees.
>> David Ossman: Yes, yes, yes.
We all live in trees
like big, fat pigs.
And it's time again to play What?
The old family fun game
that stumps the experts.
Well, yeah, that was it.
That was the state of the art
of radio back then, 1940s.
Or was it just the
art of selling soap
and cigarettes to a gullible public?
Well, we can thank
our Lucky Strikes --
>> Phil Proctor: No, that's
stars -- our lucky stars.
>> David Ossman: Ah, lucky stars,
right, yeah -- for the thoughtful,
concerned dramatists, the real
artists, the poets of the media.
>> Phil Proctor: Big
men like Awesome Whales
who scared the pants off of us.
But maybe the greatest writer
of them all was the man
who transformed the great American
art of selling into the art
of selling us a great America,
legendary radio dramatist
Normal Corwin,
who singlehandedly
yanked radio in the 1940s
by its patriotic ears
[bomb exploding].
>> David Ossman: And radio --
we love Norman, by the way,
so don't take that seriously
-- we love Norman Corwin --
radio went off to the ward.
There was nothing to stop it.
And when it came back, we discovered
another casualty rather closer
to home.
We found that suddenly [buzzing
sounds] we couldn't hear D'Forest
because of the bees.
>> Phil Proctor: You see,
a swarm of bees had buzzed
into Philo Farnsworth's head, their
little bodies forming a picture,
a vision [inaudible] and soon,
he replaced D'Forest's
bulky vacuum tube
with the new-fangled
catheter ray tube.
>> David Ossman: That's
[inaudible] ray tube.
>> Phil Proctor: Ow!
>> David Ossman: Well, then -- gee.
Well, then it was the '50s and,
well, bees were everywhere by then.
And there were B movies, B girls --
>> Phil Proctor: Be my love, for
no one else can end this yearning.
>> David Ossman: And
"Time Out for Beaver."
Well, America was really
bewitched by TV,
and everybody was bothered
and bewildered.
And radio was left to
you kids, late at night,
tucked in your beds
[snoring sounds] listening
to dangerous broadcasts
like -- Los Angeles.
He walks again by night.
[ Applause ]
Out of the fog [whistling], into
the smog, relentlessly, ruthlessly.
>> Phil Proctor: I
wonder where Ruth is?
>> David Ossman: Doggedly [barking],
toward his weekly meeting
with the unknown.
At Fourth and Drucker he turns left.
At Drucker and Fourth
he turns right.
He crosses McArthur Park and walks
into a great sandstone building.
>> Phil Proctor: [Smacking
sound] Oh, my nose!
>> David Ossman: Groping for
the door, he steps inside.
He's ready for mystery.
He's ready for excitement.
He's ready for anything.
He's Nick Danger, America's
only detective.
[ Applause ]
>> Phil Proctor: As played
so memorably by our late,
great partner Phil Austin.
[ Applause ]
>> David Ossman: Well,
there will always be a Nick,
and there will always be a Bradshaw.
>> Phil Proctor: Let's
hear it for Peter Bergman!
[ Applause ]
>> David Ossman: They're
here with us tonight,
you can be assured of that.
Well -- oh, yes, yes.
That's right.
There's Rocky Rococo.
I forgot about him, and --
>> Phil Proctor: Let's
hear it for me.
You stupid fools.
>> David Ossman: And, of course,
there's always Nancy, so --
>> Phil Proctor: What?
>> David Ossman: What?
>> Phil Proctor: [Snapping] Hello,
Detroit, Cleveland, Philadelphia,
Fresno, Denver, and all you
sweet people in Foggy Bottom.
And say, it's here.
D.C.'s favorite brew, Here Beer.
I drink it because it's here.
So if you're legal, drink Here.
And if you ain't, drink Near Here.
Let's hear it for Here Beer.
And stay tuned for all the hits,
all the time, all the same!
>> David Ossman: Yeah, that
was the way it was, wasn't it?
Well, what happened
to those crazy kids?
All you listening to that
stuff back in the 1950s --
>> Phil Proctor: '60s
-- in the '60s, they --
well, they became Boomers listening
to AM in the a.m., FM in the p.m.
on brand new stations like --
>> David Ossman: This is WBAI,
listener-suppressed radio
at 98.6 in No Work City.
And that, of course, was William
Malloch's Bowel Movement in B Minus,
as performed right here
in the Coolidge Auditorium
by the Unpronounceable Wind Symphony
Orchestra, under the direction
of Sir Muffled Foreign Name.
And this concludes the
two hours we've been able
to keep the transmitter on today.
So now if you're game,
stay stoned -- stay --
listen to the long-running
BBC classic "War
for the Throne of the Orphan King."
Here it goes.
>> Phil Proctor: As a tiny tot,
my frosty foster mother told
me not to cross the moat.
And then the monk, he did bespeak
me cast the mote from mine own eye.
And so confused, I crossed my eyes
and double-crossed the monk who fell
into the moat [splashing sound].
And then my naughty, nubile
niece Marie did bid me warning
that I play no longer by
myself, it would make me blind.
But I was blind to her entreaties,
and so I leapt into
her burning bush.
And lo, although consumed by fire,
I rose again to bite another
apple on yet another eve!
Are we not me?
If we fall, can we
not but rise again?
>> David Ossman: Oh!
>> Phil Proctor: Hot-headed,
flushed with blood,
we will not take it lying down.
We'll pop a pill and
get it any way we can!
Oh, listeners!
Save me!
>> David Ossman: Oh,
anything you want to.
And they did.
They did save radio, and
they still do, I guess.
But what about you, okay?
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah,
you are in dark,
smoke-filled rooms
listening to stuff like --
>> David Ossman: Welcome
to Side Fire.
Follow in your book
and repeat after me
as we learn three new
words in Turkish.
Towel, bath, border.
May I see your passport, please?
[ Applause ]
>> Phil Proctor: Hey -- hey, man.
You think he's going to make it?
>> David Ossman: I don't know, man.
He looks pretty sick to me.
>> Phil Proctor: Ooh!
Hey! I think he's coming around.
>> David Ossman: He's
coming around, folks.
He's going to be okay and
ready to play symptom six of --
>> Beat the Reaper!
>> David Ossman: Beat the Reaper!
>> Phil Proctor: Ed aims to
please, and so does Louise.
So don't hide arms, get
side arms at Aims Guns,
30102 Eukypa [assumed
spelling] Ridge Island School
of Design Terrace in Foggy Bottom.
>> David Ossman: [Clicking]
Tune for the Early Bird Theater
when George Mateski [assumed
spelling] danger in the form
of a beautiful woman
in [clicking] --
>> Phil Proctor: Anointed
with oil on troubled waters.
Oh, heavenly grid, help
us bear up thy standard,
our chevron shining bright
across the gulf, standing humble
on the rich field of mobile America,
here in this shell
we call [clicking] --
>> David Ossman: Howl of the Wolf
movie, presenting honest stories
of working people as told
by rich Hollywood stars.
Brought to you, as always, by --
>> Phil Proctor: Hiya, friends.
Ralph Spoilsport of
Spoilsport Motors.
[ Applause ]
-- the world's largest new used
and used new automobile dealership.
Ralph Spoilsport Motors here in
the city of Memphisema [coughing].
Let's just look at the
extras on this fabulous car.
Wire wheel spoke fenders,
two-way sneeze-through wind vent,
star-studded mudguards,
sponge-coated edible steering
column, chrome fender dents,
and factory air-conditioned air from
our fully factory-equipped factory!
It's a beautiful car,
friends, with doors to match.
Burgess Blacklist says this car was
stolen, but for you, dear friends,
the complete price, only $2500 in
easy monthly payments of $25 a week,
twice a week, and never on --
>> David Ossman: [Clicking]
Sorry, sorry, George.
>> Phil Proctor: George?
You're George.
>> David Ossman: Ralph, yeah, Ralph.
I'm George, I guess.
>> Phil Proctor: Wake up!
>> David Ossman: So
-- really, yes, yes.
It must be 4:00 in the morning.
I certainly am hungry.
Let's see what I've got
in the old fridge here.
Ate all the cookies.
Glass of green maraschino
cherries, oh!
Half a jar of mayonnaise,
and it's gone bad.
Laughing Cow cheese,
nothing to laugh at there.
Oh, my God.
My Mescaline.
Oh, it must be 40 years old by now.
It's still okay, but I need real
mushrooms, so where's the phonebook?
See, ocelots, [inaudible],
pipe nipples, postmortems --
postmortem, hmm -- pizzas.
There -- oh, good!
There we go.
Poutin's Topless Toppings.
Not sure about that.
Kim Jon-Un's, we deliver.
[ Laughter ]
Well -- ah, here we go, Nick's
Mystery Pies, dangerously delicious.
That's the ticket.
>> Phil Proctor: Nick's Pies.
How can we feed you?
>> David Ossman: Yeah, hello here.
This is George Tryabite here,
Tacoma and 200 Sector R. I want
to order the pizza to go,
and no anchovies, please.
>> Phil Proctor: Sorry,
[inaudible] in that area.
>> David Ossman: What?
You don't deliver in the Hills?
That's a bummer.
Well, I guess maybe I'll get my
mind off of eating by turning
on the all-night talk show
for some food for thought.
Ah --
>> Phil Proctor: You are listening
to NTR, National Trump Radio.
Stay tuned for chapter 13 of
Your Government in Action.
Today's installment,
the Art of the Surreal.
[ Laughter ]
>> David Ossman: This is the
Honorable Chester Cadaver.
Sure, understanding today's complex
word of the future is a little
like having bees [buzzing
sounds] live in your head.
But what does this mean?
Well, for the straight
poop about this,
let's go where I go every single
morning, centrally-located
in barely a stone's -- or a
scone's throw from the tomb
of the unregistered voter,
downstairs in the Old Grid Building
across from the Department
of Alt Facts,
right over there, beautiful
building.
Hello, Clive.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh,
come in, Chester.
>> David Ossman: Thank you.
>> Phil Proctor: You're just
in time to help me check
out this new model government.
Ivanka says it explains everything.
>> David Ossman: Oh, well,
it looks awful swampy to me.
>> Phil Proctor: Climate change.
>> David Ossman: I see.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, and look
over here in the far left wing.
That's where you work,
in the soon-to-be fracked Monumental
Bureau of Western Mythology.
>> David Ossman: Oh, yes.
We're a proud service of the
Lost Indian's Reclamation Agency.
>> Phil Proctor: And how!
>> David Ossman: How!
You said it, chief.
>> Phil Proctor: Let's
see what this model does
with this fine miniature
boxcar of industrial coke.
>> David Ossman: Oh!
Oh, yeah. Well, look at that.
Well, that's amazing there.
Look at that, it's pumped up --
look at that pumped up from the
Veterans' Tap Dance Administration.
There it goes.
There it goes up to the
Secretary of Leftovers --
that's the Department of
Redundancy Department.
And --
>> Phil Proctor: -- flips
down to the Czar of Cover-Ups.
>> David Ossman: Yes, it
rounds the Department of Spies.
>> Phil Proctor: And into the Office
of the Secretary of Failure himself.
>> David Ossman: Well,
that's shoes for industry.
Boy. Where are the humans, officer?
>> Phil Proctor: Why,
they're right here, son.
Waiting in the lobby to
use the power of that ton
of coke before the President does.
>> David Ossman: Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
>> Phil Proctor: But he never
listens to the radio, you know.
Sad.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, it's sad.
And so -- well, Phil,
I guess that's the end
of our story of the
history of radio.
>> Phil Proctor: Or
is it the beginning?
>> David Ossman: No, no, no.
It's the end.
Radio has gone blogging.
Where are Zippo and
Gorko when we need them?
Come down, fellows, come down.
>> Phil Proctor: Well, I
guess that's our story.
The history of radio, from dots
and dits to twits and tweets.
[ Applause ]
>> David Ossman: Thank you.
You know, the Firesign Theater, all
four of us, we did what we could.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, we took
that old art off the radio,
and we mashed it up with Stan
Freeburg and "Mad Magazine,"
Bob Newhart, Bob and
Ray, and Sergeant Pepper.
>> David Ossman: We skated just
head of the needle on our first LPs,
and escaped just in the nick of
time, diving through the hole
in the center of the record.
>> Phil Proctor: And although, you
know, we did a lot of big costumed
and propped shows in our younger
days, we ended up standing next
to each other, recreating with
just our voices characters
that we've lived with
for over 50 years.
>> David Ossman: Just like we're
standing here now to thank you all
for a lifetime of laughter, to
thank the Library of Congress
for dubbing us The
Beatles of Comedy.
>> Phil Proctor: I've got
blisters on me tonsils!
[ Applause ]
>> David Ossman: So I guess we have
to say good night and thanks --
>> Phil Proctor: Thank you.
>> David Ossman: -- for listening.
Anyway -- oh!
>> Phil Proctor: Wait.
>> David Ossman: We
have to prepare them.
Have to tell them what they're --
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, there's more.
>> David Ossman: --
going to do next.
There's more.
>> Phil Proctor: There's
always more.
>> David Ossman: You think
just go -- there's always more.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, I
thought we were going
to go offstage and drink, but okay.
>> David Ossman: No.
>> Phil Proctor: We'll
do that later.
>> David Ossman: After show.
Well, prepare yourselves for
what is really a rare treat.
>> Phil Proctor: Ah!
>> David Ossman: This is
a selection of home movies
of the recording sessions
at Columbia Records
in Hollywood, Studio B, in 1970 --
>> Phil Proctor: Wow!
>> David Ossman: -- of "Don't Crush
that Dwarf, Hand Me the Pliers."
You will actually see us in
the studio making this album.
And it's from "Plug In,"
our newly-released --
recently-released two-DVD set
of Firesign Films, available,
like most of our other
material, at FiresignTheater.com.
There's a lot of stuff out there.
>> Phil Proctor: But first --
>> David Ossman: Oh, yes.
>> Phil Proctor: -- Dave, let
me introduce my dear partner,
my co-anchor and ball-and-chain.
Late afternoon twice Gimme
[assumed spelling] Award nominee,
Harold Hiphugger.
>> David Ossman: Thank you.
Thank you, Ray.
Ray Hamburger, ladies and gentlemen,
the Kiwanis Honorable Mention
International Toastmaster Runner
Up Emeritus.
>> Phil Proctor: Twice
the experience.
>> David Ossman: Two
times the coverage.
>> D and Phil Proctor:
Double the now.
>> David Ossman: And
now -- double the now.
Oh [kissing sounds].
Hell, we're great.
>> Phil Proctor: Still together.
>> David Ossman: Still
together after all these years.
>> Phil Proctor: It's
in the contract.
>> David Ossman: So
we would like you
to welcome once again
back our patron here
in the historic Library
of Congress --
>> Phil Proctor: America's
sonic curator, Mr. Matt Barton.
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
come back Matt.
>> Phil Proctor: Come
out of the darkness!
[Applause] Come into the light!
[ Applause ]
>> David Ossman: Okay, Matt, we
hope you might aid us in making
up something to explain these clips.
>> Phil Proctor: And then
in the segment that follows,
we will attempt to answer
questions from you, the audience.
>> David Ossman: As long as we can
remember who we are and what we did.
>> Phil Proctor: And why we're here.
>> David Ossman: And why we're here.
>> Phil Proctor: But now, let's
watch this together, okay.
>> David Ossman: Should
we roll our things off --
>> Phil Proctor: Do a
little arrangement here.
>> David Ossman: --
off the stage here?
>> Phil Proctor: Yes,
get things off the stage.
We always [inaudible].
Not my cigar.
>> Matthew Barton: All right.
>> Phil Proctor: This here
[inaudible] prepared material --
>> David Ossman: Going
onto the repaired material.
How's this?
>> Matthew Barton: Get
ready to roll that video.
>> David Ossman: Ready
to roll that video.
Okay, just to set -- to
set you up on this --
>> Matthew Barton:
Just a moment, though.
>> David Ossman: -- this
is Columbia Records, 1970.
We're surrounded by rock-and-rollers
in all the other studios.
We ourselves are a rock band, they
think, because they don't know.
You know, they're just
a record company.
What do they know?
So what you're going to see
in the next 15 minutes --
about 15 minutes of home movies --
they're [inaudible]
like all home movies.
But it will take you back
to a time and a place
that simply doesn't exist anymore.
Columbia Records, 1970, all of the
artists coming out of these studios.
And you know, you've got to say
I think we look a little like --
sort of like The Beatles in this.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, there you go.
All right.
>> David Ossman: Roll them.
[ Birds Chirping ]
>> David Ossman: Little title done
by my children, Allison and Devon.
[ Music ]
>> Matthew Barton: Man,
that 16-track recording really
makes a visual difference,
doesn't it [laughter]?
>> David Ossman: Phil, Peter.
Our engineer, Bill Dremel
[assumed spelling], Phil Austin.
Here's a little experimental
movie stuff here.
These are -- you know,
they pay lots of money
for this kind of stuff, you know.
>> Phil Proctor: Great special
effects in this thing, I tell you.
>> David Ossman: Freshly
brewed, you know.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, that
was where it was with Columbia
in those days, self-service
cold buffet.
>> David Ossman: Here we come.
Pete and Phil Austin
looking just as they did
at the top -- oh, who's that?
>> Phil Proctor: That's a young man.
>> David Ossman: Had a
lot of hair on there.
>> Phil Proctor: Lot
of hair everywhere.
>> David Ossman: And me,
yeah, long hair, too.
>> Phil Proctor: It was
awfully dark in the studio.
>> David Ossman: Here
is everything --
>> Phil Proctor: It helped
us, the mood, you know.
Ah, but --
>> David Ossman: Everything was,
of course, recorded in 16-track.
This was our first album that
allowed us to use 16-track.
And the -- for anybody who
knows about this kind of thing,
there is a lot of accumulated
noise [static sounds]
on those open tracks.
So what are we going to
do about all this noise?
Well, we got something
called Dolby back here.
We'll roll them in.
And so that was the very first
album that incorporated Dolbys
in to suppress the tracks.
We always had the same engineer.
You'll see him frequently.
These are people we
probably still know.
>> Phil Proctor: And actually,
the Firesign Theater gave Mr. Dolby
his lifetime achievement award --
or his Dolby Award, anyway, for
creating it, invention award.
All right, let's see
what' going on here now.
What's that?
>> David Ossman: Oh, just
current news headlines.
There's a lot of spare time in
the studio, as you can tell.
That's That Warrick who
did the music for "Dwarf."
David Grimm was our organist
on the "Nick Danger" album.
And he passed away very
unexpectedly shortly
after that album was released,
or he would have been with us --
>> Phil Proctor: Had
rheumatic heart --
>> David Ossman: -- as well.
>> Phil Proctor: --
condition, poor fellow.
>> David Ossman: Yes
-- at 30 years old.
>> Phil Proctor: Ah,
yes, there we are.
That's the control board
[inaudible] from "Star Trek."
>> David Ossman: Little
clock on the wall.
>> Phil Proctor: That little
clock on the wall, that's right.
>> David Ossman: We don't
know what he's saying.
>> Phil Proctor: But we
weren't listening anyway.
Anyway, this was an
old radio studio.
All of the studios that we
worked in those early days
at Columbia Square were radio
studios in the '40s and '50s.
And they still stood there,
and that's where we
did our first albums.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, they -- it
still had the old director's booth
up the wall that he could -- and
"Suspense" was done in this studio.
I think many other
CBS shows of the time.
>> Phil Proctor: Shows you
how much space you needed
to do radio properly.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, right.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, we liked
to do things as live as we could
in those days, so we spread out.
We got a big studio.
Now these are some of
the ladies who are going
to be singing the Porgy
Tirebiter song later.
>> David Ossman: Jane
Dancey [assumed spelling],
Liz Plum [assumed spelling].
>> Phil Proctor: Beautiful Liz Plum.
>> David Ossman: And that's Anna
Leigh Austin [assumed spelling] --
>> Phil Proctor: Phil's
wife at the time.
I believe that Matt has
told me there is going
to be not only an archives
room, but an ex-wives room
for the Firesign Theater [laughter].
Right, Matt?
>> Matthew Barton: Yes,
yes, we have an opening
for a three-dimensional curator.
>> Phil Proctor: Excellent.
>> David Ossman: Good.
>> Matthew Barton: I just do sound.
>> Phil Proctor: Good,
there I am warming up.
Now you notice that we've got
these very large headphones
in those days, earphones.
They were actually called
hair phones in those days,
because everybody had so much
hair, they had to be especially big
and loud to get through to our ears.
It's true technologically.
>> Matthew Barton: Looks
like we've had a big
of a ghost in the machine there.
>> Phil Proctor: Yes, yes.
>> David Ossman: The CBS door.
>> Phil Proctor: Yes,
the CBS door which,
with some other sound effects
-- oh, the concrete hand job.
I forgot about that.
It was a special service
of CBS in those days.
Yes, there it is.
Right, yes, scary.
I know, I know.
Anyway, we found a lot of
these sound effects units
down in the basement.
They were going to throw them
out, and I brought them all up,
and one of them was
this wonderful door,
which we used in so many records.
And then finally, Stan Freeburg
inherited the door from Fred Jones,
one of our long-lasting
engineers, wonderful engineer.
And he, I think, has it to this day.
Well, he -- no, he doesn't have
it to this day because he's gone.
But the door remains.
That's art for you.
Okay, so --
>> David Ossman: So really there
are no barriers in this studio.
They're just widely-separated,
wonderful RCA mics
that were invented
in 1938 just for us.
And of course, we had
to go find them.
"Are there any other microphones
than these that we could use?"
"Oh, I think there's a
big cabinet over there."
You open it up and there's
thousands of dollars' worth
of classic, beautiful microphones.
These are the -- and you'll see --
at the end of this,
you'll see the whole --
>> Phil Proctor: You'll
actually hear them singing.
>> David Ossman: --
Porgy Tirebiter song.
But these are the girls singing it.
>> Phil Proctor: Do you have
a collection of microphones?
I imagine you do.
>> Matthew Barton: We do.
That's why I've been
trying to lure you
down to Culpepper, show off our --
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, they're
in Culpepper, are they?
>> Matthew Barton: Yes,
show off our collection.
>> Phil Proctor: Well,
take some pictures.
Show off your what?
>> Matthew Barton: Show off --
>> Phil Proctor: Never mind.
Some things are better left unsaid.
There they go, yes.
They were all singing, but the
Dolby system silenced them all.
Really sad.
Very sad.
>> Matthew Barton:
That's some filter.
>> Phil Proctor: Yes, it is.
It was a micronite
filter, I believe.
>> David Ossman: Our
archivist, Taylor Jessen,
who for some reason
is not here tonight --
you're not here, are you Taylor?
>> Phil Proctor: For some reason?
>> David Ossman: He should be here.
Taylor has prepared
our really quite big --
it's a big archive, let me tell you.
And in this piece of film you'll
see he has matched some voices.
So you'll see lines coming
up that are actually
the lines being recorded
at that moment in the studio.
Clever guy.
That's --
>> Phil Proctor: Which David
will magically try to recreate.
>> David Ossman: Yes,
I will, I will.
>> Phil Proctor: Twiddling
dials, yes, or pretending to.
That's me pretending to know
what I'm doing, I think.
>> David Ossman: We didn't get
to actually mix an album until
"Giant Rat of Sumatra,"
which we did at RCA.
And that was the first time we
could actually put our hands
on that board.
Otherwise, we had to call it
fade [inaudible] fade, so forth.
>> Phil Proctor: Could
you be -- who's that?
>> David Ossman: Stravinsky.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, of
course, of course, Stravinsky.
>> David Ossman: I don't
know why, but there he is.
>> Phil Proctor: Inspiration.
There's Mr. Bergman.
He does not have the same hair
problem that the rest of us had.
Politics of pain, ah, yes.
Bill Dremel wearing
an engineer's cap.
He was really getting into it.
>> David Ossman: He did like
four or five of our albums, Bill.
Always had -- you know, there
was always a second engineer
that was involved with it,
but he was the chief for us.
That look --
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, the
whistler, the whistler.
Don't you love this record?
It's "The Organ of the Birds."
So sweet.
>> David Ossman: Oh, come on, Liz!
Only another hour to go.
We'll be there soon.
Ah, Phil Austin.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh,
that's a Moog synthesizer.
>> David Ossman: That's the
Moog synthesizer we were using
on the album.
Just had a little shot of it.
>> Phil Proctor: What, it's
about this big now, right?
I've got one on my wrist, right?
>> David Ossman: [Laughter] Right.
Jane was somebody's girlfriend.
>> Phil Proctor: The
guitar was taking a rest.
>> David Ossman: Phil
was dragging it.
>> Phil Proctor: Sound effects.
>> David Ossman: He's sound effects.
Yes, sound effects
guy trying to make --
>> Phil Proctor: I loved creating
sound effects in those days.
Found --
>> David Ossman: And you had all
that big studio space to do it in.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah.
Don't quite know what that is.
>> David Ossman: Oh --
>> Phil Proctor: Looks
psychedelic, though.
>> David Ossman: A lot
of time -- there's Nurgi.
Peter's dog Nurgi.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh,
That's --
>> David Ossman: Yeah, he was
with us for a long, long time.
Very sweet companion.
>> Phil Proctor: Started the
documentary film service, remember?
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
Nurgi Clockwork Films.
>> Phil Proctor: Nurgi
Clockwork Films.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, oh, yes.
>> Phil Proctor: That was him.
>> David Ossman: Pete, are
you doing something illegal?
I guess not.
>> Phil Proctor: No, he was just --
he was rolling regular
cigarettes, remember?
>> David Ossman: Yeah, I see.
Okay.
>> Phil Proctor: That explains it.
>> David Ossman: His
dog was leaving him.
Terrible.
>> Phil Proctor: He had to smoke
in there because Nurgi had one
of those very short little
dog intestinal systems,
constantly making his presence
known [farting sounds], you know.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: Peter smoked
to counteract it, right.
>> Matthew Barton: How long
did these sessions last?
>> Phil Proctor: Oh,
about six to eight hours.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, probably
you're watching three sessions here.
This is right toward
the end of the album.
We're recording the courtroom scene.
You'll see it's coming
up -- from "Dwarf."
>> Phil Proctor: Ooh,
more sound effects.
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
six hour -- six hour.
Yeah, we tried to get three
minutes down [laughter].
>> Matthew Barton: Three --
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
three minutes.
Three produced minutes.
Are you kidding?
That's fast work.
>> Phil Proctor: The
board there looked
like an old telephone
operator's board, didn't it?
With -- you see all of
the wires and everything.
All gone now.
Wireless. We've become
wireless again.
We went from wireless to
wireless, strange continuity.
>> David Ossman: Emily just had an
endless time playing the guitar --
playing the drums.
She really liked that.
There's a lot of time to fill here,
which is part of the
experience of recording.
We're listening back.
We're setting up the studio.
We're rewriting the script.
We're practicing the music.
We're opening and closing
the stupid door.
[ Laughter ]
>> Phil Proctor: And now
we're hopelessly bored.
The day is nearly over.
Let's take pictures of each other.
Okay, oh, yeah.
Taking pictures of people
taking pictures of you,
and you taking pictures of us
taking pictures of one another.
>> David Ossman: There's
the script --
>> Phil Proctor: --
or something like it.
>> David Ossman: And that
script is here right now
at the Library of Congress.
That script.
>> Phil Proctor: Wow.
>> David Ossman: We felt they
should -- if they've got the record,
they should have the
script for it, you know.
[ Music ]
And you also -- you have
like all four scripts, right?
>> Matthew Barton: Well, yeah,
it's quite an item, actually.
It's all of the --
>> Phil Proctor: That's it.
That's the machine.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, and each one
of them had our own
writing on it as well.
>> Matthew Barton: Exactly,
you can see all the
iterations, all the revisions.
>> Phil Proctor: Pretty interesting.
>> Matthew Barton: Yeah.
No, it's quite an item in itself.
>> Phil Proctor: Now
Dave, are you about to --
>> David Ossman: Yeah, here we go.
>> Phil Proctor: -- do some acting?
>> David Ossman: This is --
>> Phil Proctor: Here we go.
>> David Ossman: --
Lieutenant Tirebiter.
>> Phil Proctor: The
courtroom scene.
>> David Ossman: I am out, Klein.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, yeah.
>> David Ossman: "I don't like you.
I don't want a piece, and
I'm walking out of your set."
Literally, and close the door.
All in one movement.
And this is Brockmer
[assumed spelling].
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, but I'm --
>> David Ossman: This
is the courtroom scene.
Not sure what these lines are,
but it's in the midst of recording
that sequence of the --
toward the end of the album.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah,
he would change his voice
by sticking pencils in his mouth.
Interesting technique.
>> David Ossman: Well,
in fact, to do the --
is he walking through the door now?
It's just hopeless.
>> Phil Proctor: He's
walking through --
the engineer is walking
through the door.
>> David Ossman: Everybody
got a piece of that door.
[ Music ]
>> Phil Proctor: That was a
door to another dimension.
>> David Ossman: Oh, let's move
in another microphone,
see how that works.
Paul McCartney.
>> Phil Proctor: Phil was --
>> David Ossman: It's
Paul McCartney.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah,
Paul McCartney, right.
Phil was our musical backbone.
Ah, here we go.
>> David Ossman: "I got
so I drink anything.
After that, I couldn't
seem to get off the stuff.
My whole career went up in smoke.
There was no way I could follow
the scenario written by the people
who pay for your wheelchairs,
General!"
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah,
Bergman's listening.
You could always tell when
he was listening intently.
That's how he lost the hair
on the top of his head.
[ Laughter ]
Listening, listening.
>> David Ossman: So we'd
probably been in the studio now
for two months, off and on.
>> Matthew Barton: Is that how
long it took to do that album?
>> David Ossman: Yeah, it
was from May -- I mean -
>> Matthew Barton: Took a while.
>> David Ossman: May -- April, May.
So all of April and May we worked.
>> Matthew Barton: How much
changed just in that time?
About how much changed
just in that time?
[Inaudible] do we see in the script?
>> David Ossman: This is probably
the last three sessions in --
what I would guess, because this
is really toward the very end
of it now.
A lot of listening back.
How does the record sound?
Let's play back the tracks.
>> [Inaudible] there.
>> Phil Proctor: This is --
yeah, "You take off your
shoes to evade them men
who are trying to protect you."
That's Dad -- Phil is dad.
>> David Ossman: Now you notice the
love beads that Peter is wearing,
they are banned in studios now
because they make too much noise.
But with the Dolby system we
could get away with that, you see.
This is classic listening back.
>> Phil Proctor: Listening.
>> David Ossman: Play it back.
Let's play it back.
Let's listen to it.
>> Phil Proctor: Classic
watching and watching.
>> David Ossman: Is
it going to work?
Is it going to work?
Watching and listening.
Is that funny?
Are my pants funny?
Is my hat funny?
>> Matthew Barton: Okay, see.
That's okay.
That's good with me.
>> Phil Proctor: And you notice
David's earphones are even bigger
than ours because it had
to get through the hat.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
>> Phil Proctor: You laugh, but it
was state of the art at the time.
>> David Ossman: All right,
close your eyes, please.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, yes.
>> David Ossman: Close your eyes.
>> Phil Proctor: Saying
goodbye to your -- wife --
trading your wife in for a new one?
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
No, it was long ago.
>> Phil Proctor: Do you
really want a divorce?
>> David Ossman: No, I --
>> Phil Proctor: [Chuckling]
That's okay.
I'm not here anyway.
Goodbye. Send me a check.
>> David Ossman: Oh!
I'm devastated.
How am I going to send her a check?
I can't --
>> Phil Proctor: This is the
"Divorce Rag," I think it is.
Call a lawyer.
We'll divide everything
equally between our two lawyers.
He's wearing a confederate cap,
you see, for inspiration, I guess.
And he's got those
confederate pants on.
That' why they lost the war.
Or did they?
>> Boo!
>> Phil Proctor: Thank you.
Here we are in the belly
of the beast, boys.
Ah, speaking of the beast.
>> David Ossman: There's the
sound effects right there.
>> Phil Proctor: Sound effects.
See, now you know how we did it.
>> David Ossman: Just push that
music stand right over, no problem.
>> Phil Proctor: Push
that stand over!
It's easy to do.
All you have to do is just --
okay, everyone get ready to sing.
[Inaudible] this, watch me.
Watch my hands.
And here we go.
I was wrong.
We didn't start yet.
Okay. What's he saying?
>> David Ossman: "You mean you're
going to trade this four-foot cube
of 18-carat Swiss bullion
and the snake knives
all for that little bag?
Well, all right, then, yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: This
is a bag of shit, yeah.
>> David Ossman: But it's
good shit, [inaudible].
That's right.
[ Applause ]
>> Phil Proctor: I'll take --
>> David Ossman: "Are you going
to hit this Jew over the head
with a bag of sugar, or beat
out that rhythm on a drum?"
>> Phil Proctor: Nothing's changed.
>> David Ossman: "You mean you're
going to trade this four-foot cube
of 18-carat Swiss --
take two, obviously.
>> Phil Proctor: Oh, it must
have been take two -- take two.
>> David Ossman: "And the
snake knives, Ms. [inaudible]."
There it is.
That's the real take.
The other one was just --
that was just rehearsal, yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: No,
we didn't rehearse.
We recorded everything,
didn't we, Dave?
Do you remember?
>> David Ossman: Pretty much.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, pretty much.
>> David Ossman: Pretty
much recorded all the tape.
>> Phil Proctor: Tape was cheap.
You could always record over
it if you didn't like it.
So now --
>> David Ossman: We'll just go on
-- this is going to run on and --
>> Phil Proctor: We're
going to stop talking.
>> Glorious sound-a-phonic sound.
[ Music ]
>> Porgy Tirebiter.
He's a spy and a girl delighter.
Porgy Tirebiter, he's
a student like you.
If you're looking for a
captain of the ring ball team,
you can bet he won't be there.
You'll find him a-popping
up at Pop's Sodium Shop.
Do-do-do-do-do, wahoo-oo,
doobie do-wop.
Porgy Tirebiter, just
a student like you.
>> Like me?
>> Just a student like you.
>> Stop singing and
finish your homework.
>> Just a student like you.
>> David Ossman: And that's that.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, that's actually the way
it was for the first five albums
that we did at Columbia in
that studio with that engineer.
And -- oh, yes.
I'm sorry.
Microphone, thank you.
My real wife, Judith, has
-- is the techie here.
[ Applause ]
But here's what -- I want
to tell you one little story
before we start the Q&A.
Twenty-five years ago -- ha --
everybody was out on
the road doing their --
every rock band was doing
their 25th anniversary show.
We were all out there
doing, you know, 25 years --
one of those historic moments.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah --
>> David Ossman: So we were
out on the road doing it.
And at our -- the last performance
of that show in some city
in California -- Northern
California somewhere,
I was able to take the last bow
with my very, very young son Preston
who is 25 years old tonight.
Give him a big hand!
[ Applause ]
Stand up!
Yes, he heard that first burst of
applause at about three months.
It changes your life.
And I've got to introduce Orson,
our other wonderful son, Orson.
There he is.
[ Applause ]
>> Phil Proctor: Since
we're acknowledging family,
I want to acknowledge my
wonderful wife, Melinda Peterson
who helped us direct
this piece tonight.
Wherever you are.
I love you, darling!
Hey, there she is!
[Applause] Thank you all.
>> David Ossman: So are
there any questions?
Front row.
>> Phil Proctor: Let's see, have
we got a traveling microphone?
>> David Ossman: There it is.
>> Phil Proctor: Mr. Microphone.
>> David Ossman: Pass
that mic along.
>> Thank you very much.
Matt Stone and Trey
Barker were quoted
in the last year saying they're
really stymied when it comes
to the Trump Administration because
any satire they do can't come
up to the measure of the real thing.
And I'm wondering,
those contemporary young
and future humorists who are
following in your footsteps,
where are they going to go
with what you've started?
And can they with what
you've started?
>> David Ossman: Well, I think
two things have happened.
One is stand-up, which was the
opposite of what we were doing.
We were the anti-stand-up
when we started.
And that's really changed a
lot of the landscape out there.
Television -- when you think
of "Saturday Night Live,"
sketch humor, and it's
direct satire.
What the Firesign Theater
never did was direct.
It was always indirect
and somewhat surreal.
You know, all of our
commercials are not --
you know, they were way
over there, you know.
the reason we were never
on "Saturday Night Live" is
because we were just too
-- we were too crazy.
We were too hot for them.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, also, they
really were inspired by a group
like us to create their
own repertory company.
And we were -- you
know, it's hard enough
to get two guys on television.
And it was really difficult to
get four guys on television.
But for other reasons -- but one of
the things that's also happening,
obviously there are some
very powerful comedians
who are doing some great satire
in a time when we need to laugh
about the dire situation
that we find ourselves in.
And that was never really what
Firesign Theater set out to do.
Although, we did break
the President, all right.
Yes, we did.
Four more gears, yeah.
>> David Ossman: I think --
you know, I think it comes from
the news better than it comes
from the comedians, if you ask me.
The people who are doing news
kinds of programs are the ones --
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah, right.
>> David Ossman: -- who are
really having a satiric effect
on politics right now.
Very, very valuable.
>> Phil Proctor: But remember
also, one of the main messages
that we tried to deliver in the
many years that we created comedy
in our own particular way was
that you're responsible
for everything, really.
You know, the tomb
of the unregistered voter is
a classic example of that.
You know, we are responsible,
in many ways, for the situations
that we create in our
society and in our lives.
But the other side of that
message is kind of like,
but don't get too emotionally
or spiritually involved in it,
because much of it is really,
at the bottom line, an illusion.
And we always like to reveal
the illusion of things
that we were all getting
emotionally involved
in so people could sell us things.
People could scare us into
thinking certain ways,
voting certain ways,
acting certain ways.
So you have to maintain
your own inner perspective.
And that was, I always felt,
one of the main messages
of Firesign Theater, which is
I'm responsible for my life,
and I'm going to keep it that way.
>> David Ossman: Absolutely,
very strong.
Yeah, he's handing the mic over.
Yep?
>> Gentlemen, thank you.
>> Phil Proctor: Well,
that's very nice.
Thank you.
>> Is this thing on?
>> Phil Proctor: It sure is.
>> Jameson Hawkins, Facebook
friend, he told me to shout-out.
I did.
>> Phil Proctor: Excellent.
>> Speaking of breaking
precedence, where in the name
of fud did you come up with the idea
in 1970 or '71 to put holograms,
and clones, and a computer
hacker together for Bozos?
>> David Ossman: Well, that
was 1971, and the story is --
>> Phil Proctor: We went to --
did everybody go to that
work fair, or was it just me?
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
we were all there.
>> Phil Proctor: Everybody
went -- we went to a work fair,
I guess doing a little R&D.
Or was it -- was there
an ulterior motive?
>> David Ossman: It was just -- I
don't remember why we were there.
>> Phil Proctor: I think it
was just a cultural event.
We were at a work fair in Hollywood.
And I came across a thing
called the ELIZA program.
Do any of you know what that is?
Yes, if you do.
The ELIZA program was a very, very
early interactive computer program.
And it was quite crude.
You basically would
type a question in,
and the program was a
psychiatric program.
You would be talking
to a psychiatrist.
And the psychiatrist would be
answering you through the machine.
And answer whatever questions --
"How do you feel about that, Phil?"
You know, things like that.
And I noticed -- and I played it.
It was fascinating.
You know, other people
were playing it.
But I noticed that all of the
material was printed out on one
of those -- the yellow sheets of
paper, like the ticker-type paper
that used to come out
of all the machines.
You remember?
And it was going into
a big cardboard barrel.
And I said, "Ooh, this is
too good not to partake of."
So I dove into the barrel, and
I came out with reams and reams
of this paper and skedaddled
out of the place eventually,
brought it to our writing
session the next day.
And what was also interesting was it
had the computer programming printed
out in it as well,
"Unhappy mac nam."
You know, all this strange --
>> David Ossman: Uptime 901.
>> Phil Proctor: DR memory.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, Dr. Memory.
>> Phil Proctor: Dr. Memory.
Direct readout memory.
Dr. Memory.
And so it became an integral
part of our investigation
into the inner workings of this
future fair, which is, of course,
a metaphor -- Disney World
basically was telling everybody
that the future is now, and
it's absolutely wonderful.
You know, our -- the
government is doing a great job.
Everybody's going to have a job.
Nothing's changed.
It's all the same stuff -- all
the same B.S. But basically,
that was the inspiration for all
of the computer language
and everything.
One other thing I should
say, I can't demonstrate it,
because I had to turn my
phone off, but if you --
some of you know this,
some of you don't.
If you have an iPhone
and you ask Siri --
you say to Siri, "This
is worker speaking.
Hello." She will say to
you, "Hello, Ah-Clem.
What function can I perform for you?
LOL." Why, you may
ask, did that happen?
Well, Dave Ossman and I were
both involved in Pixar movies,
and we did "A Bug's Life."
Dave had a major role
in "A Bug's Life."
You were Phyllis Diller's
right-hand man.
>> David Ossman: Yes, her consort.
>> Phil Proctor: You were
her consort, that's right.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: Using that --
>> David Ossman: Cornelius.
>> Phil Proctor: Using
that wonderful voice
that he was born with.
>> David Ossman: Aye, this is how
I end up screwing up this voice.
>> Phil Proctor: I've been doing --
>> David Ossman: The ant costume
was very tough to get into.
>> Phil Proctor: I've been doing
Pixar and Disney movies for a while.
And Lassiter, who is a
Firesign fan, loved that voice
of David's, the [inaudible] voice.
And asked me how to
get in touch with him.
And so Dave and I were both
involved in that particular movie.
And at the opening cast and crew
party up in San Francisco --
>> David Ossman: Oakland.
>> Phil Proctor: In Oakland was it?
>> David Ossman: Yeah, I think
it was the Oakland Paramount.
>> Phil Proctor: I met Steve Jobs,
because he had invested
in the Pixar company.
And he told me he was a big fan.
He was a Fire Head.
And we had inspired him with the
record "I Think We're All Bozos
on this Bus" to move
forward with his --
to create his computer empire.
And he put that into
the Siri program
as an homage to the
Firesign Theater.
Thank you, Steve!
[ Applause ]
>> David Ossman: And
just to wrap that up,
the idea of a computer hacker
had never, ever been thought
of until Mr. Proctor walked into --
his character walked into the
future fair and discovered how
to clone himself, send
the clone back to the --
in the mainframe of the
machine and ask it a question
that couldn't be answered.
>> That's right.
Why does a porridge bird
lay his egg in the air?
Can't be answered by
yes or no, you see.
Can't be answered anyway.
>> David Ossman: Next question.
The mic -- mic, right there.
Short -- or there's one over there.
Let's have that one.
>> Hola, Philippe.
Como estas?
>> Muy bien, gracias.
>> [Inaudible] out
"Belly of the Beast."
I was wondering if those other
Beatles ever looked you guys up,
and whether you ever had
any interactions with them?
>> David Ossman: With who?
>> The other Beatles.
The --
>> David Ossman: The other Beatles.
The rest of those wonderful Beatles.
>> Well, I met --
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
>> I met John Lennon once
in the Los Filez area.
And I went up to him and told
him what a great admirer I was
and how he inspired
Firesign Theater, so --
to go our happy, surrealistic way.
He knew who we were.
And I was wearing a George
Baboon for President --
for Resident, Not Insane
button, and I gave it to him.
And you will occasionally
see a picture of him with --
wearing the Firesign
Theater Not Insane button.
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
there's actually a beautiful,
beautiful picture of John and Yoko,
and John is wearing
that Not Insane button.
It's just priceless.
>> Not Insane.
But that was the only
interaction other than the fact
that we would religiously
get together and listen
to the first pressing that
we could get our hands
on of every new Beatles album.
>> David Ossman: Oh,
yeah, and we started
when "Radio Free oZ" started.
It was before "Sergeant Pepper,"
and we were playing all of those.
Peter had a wonderful
thing that he worked
out with -- he -- 12 cuts, okay.
And he said, "Oh, this is an
astrological album," his first cut.
And it's "Revolver," right?
>> "Revolver."
>> David Ossman: Yeah,
it's "Revolver."
And Peter had this
whole thing that he made
up that everybody believed
[laughter].
Everybody believed it.
That was Peter's real skill, to
make everybody believe something.
And of course, when he found
out that there were actually
eight tracks [inaudible],
didn't work out that way.
Yeah, next one?
>> Is it here or there?
>> Hi, guys.
The last time I saw you
I was interviewing you
for "Feast Your Ears,
the Story of WHFS."
>> Jay, hi, Jay.
Jay Schlossberg, ladies
and gentlemen.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I think it's really fitting that
you did the history of radio
as your thing tonight, since
I'm telling a story about one
of the greatest radio stations
to grace the airwaves, WHFS.
Before I ask the question, though, I
want you to know that two of the DJs
that played your records
all the time are here.
One is Weasel in the
orange shirt right here.
>> David Ossman: Weasel, all right.
>> Yay!
[ Applause ]
You're a sleazy Weasel.
I love you!
>> Squeeze the Weas.
And then sitting back
here is Adele Abrams --
>> Hey, Adele.
[ Applause ]
They love you, too,
but in a different way.
>> So the question
I wanted to ask you
because you did this
radio history was --
it's a question I actually asked
you for the film, and so what I'd
like to ask is what did freeform
progressive radio do for you?
How did that light the fire
behind those records, because HFS,
and WBAI, and BCN, and all those 30,
40 stations around the country were
the only ones playing your records.
So maybe you could answer a
little question about that.
>> David Ossman: Yeah, well, part
of the reason why we were able
to reach people was
also that FM radio --
the FM radio revolution
happened around that time,
and a lot of college stations
were experimenting with it,
and they could play an
entire side of an album.
But freeform radio was -- you
know, it was the key to our success
because our albums were
designed to mimic the sound
of actual radio and television.
And so people who didn't
know that we were comedians
or surrealists would
get hooked on that.
And then, believing
that it was normal,
[laughter] we could
pervert their young minds.
That's my --
>> David Ossman: Yeah, no.
We couldn't have done without
progressive radio, obviously.
We did the "Dear Friends" album
which were three-minute cuts
from our radio program, because we
could only get airplay eventually.
We couldn't get 38
minutes of record on.
>> Short cuts.
>> David Ossman: Could you get
38 minutes of record on now?
No, I don't think so.
So without your station
and stations like yours,
particularly on the East
Coast -- GBH -- ah, yeah.
>> GBD, yeah, right.
>> David Ossman: Yep.
>> Yeah, see.
>> David Ossman: We couldn't
have done it without you.
>> Thank you all.
>> David Ossman: Really
couldn't have.
>> And David and I did
participate in your documentary,
and it's quite wonderful
and fascinating.
We're very grateful for
people like yourselves
to fearlessly play the stuff
that we were doing, which --
pretty far out to an
audience of real people.
>> Phil Proctor: You
made them surreal.
Thank you.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
What else?
>> Phil Proctor: Oh,
I should also mention
that Luke Polling is
in the house tonight.
I'm polling.
I don't know where Luke is,
but Luke is doing a documentary
on the Firesign Theatre and Dave
and I did some interviewing
with him back stage.
It's very exciting and he's got
about 70 minutes done right now.
So that's another documentary piece.
I got to get you two guys together.
We're looking forward --
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
As far as I've -- just before
you get the next question,
we are doing a really
wonderful job of wrapping it up.
So all of the albums, all of the
radio shows, all of the movies,
all of the scripts for
all of the material,
most of that is out,
coming out very soon.
Our two books, mine --
>> Phil Proctor: Dribs and drabs.
>> David Ossman: One is a novel
starring George Tirebiter,
the flying saucer murder case.
There's some handouts
around about that.
And then, after that,
fighting clowns of Hollywood,
which is the story of us to make it
when we didn't have a record label,
righting big, big theatrical shows
and all of those scripts will be
in there and then there'll
be a third book coming,
which is the unmade film
scripts, the original version
of Zachariah, which is really funny.
And --
>> Phil Proctor: Saucer.
>> David Ossman: Saucer,
which Phil lost
and then I wrote right
after Airplane.
We were hired to write Saucer with
a tale -- and they never made it.
And -- but the big one was the
Firesign Theatre's one big movie.
What are we going to do?
We're going to make The Odyssey.
>> Phil Proctor: Modernize
the Odyssey.
>> David Ossman: What?
And so, the script -- all
those scripts will be --
and all of these books
are from Bear Manor.
You could go to their
website and they'll have all
of our -- all of those books.
>> Phil Proctor: And then,
in honor of Peter Bergman,
Peter and I have been
working on a couple
of projects before he passed away.
And so, in honor of
him, I completed them.
one is Power, which is the scripts
of a very funny surrealistic
radio series we did for Heat
with John Hockenberry, produced
by our friend Ted Bonnet,
and my wife Melinda
plays many roles on it.
It's very funny and it
has been available on CD.
But the scripts are very, very funny
and that's also a Bear
Manor Press project.
And I'm putting the
finishing touches now
on the skits behind Americathon.
The skits behind the screenplay
of Americathon, telling the story
of that movie, which had the
potential to be a lot better
than it was, but is
a cult classic now.
And finally, my own autobiography,
Where Is My Fortune Cookie?,
is just released today.
You can get it on Amazon and I'll be
doing promotion on shows like Coast
to Coast soon talking about it.
Because it's really about
the psychedelic events
that happened during -- that
led me really to become a member
of the Firesign Theatre and to stay
with the group over all the years.
And I hope you get a
kick out of that as well.
[ Applause ]
>> In the history of a creative
enterprise, whether it's individual
or collective, there's often a
moment where the participants
or participant looks in the
mirror, looks at one another,
look at one another, and
say we could do this.
Is there such a moment
in your experience
with the Firesign Theatre
than you can talk about?
>> Phil Proctor: Instant.
>> David Ossman: It was instant.
Here's what happened.
Peter says let's do
the Oz Film Festival.
We're all filmmakers and we're going
to show the movies on the radio.
And I was one person
and he was two people
and Phil Austin was four
people and Peter was the host.
And we got in.
We started showing
our movies and the --
immediately, people believed this.
They believed that we were showing
movies in the studio on the radio.
>> Phil Proctor: Here's
what really sold it for us.
Phil Austin was playing Jack Love,
who is a pioneer in adult movies.
And it was Phil Austin.
He did it with a sleazy
British accent and he wanted
to show excerpts from his latest
movie Blondie Pays the Rent.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
Something like that.
Yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: So he
sets the projector up
and he starts to play it.
And Bergman says stop.
No. Stop, stop, stop.
We can't show a dirty
movie on the radio.
They'll take away my license.
And the phones lit up.
>> David Ossman: Lit up.
>> Phil Proctor: People --
>> David Ossman: KPF-K --
Pacific Radio, if you can imagine.
>> Phil Proctor: KPF-K.
How can you censor this
man from showing his movie?
He's an artist?
That's when we looked at
one another and went --
>> David Ossman: Said uh-huh.
>> Phil Proctor: We got
something going here.
>> David Ossman: So it was really
our first performance together
that did it.
Yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah.
>> We have a little time.
One or two.
>> A voice from the darkness.
Yes.
>> Well, first of all,
thanks for coming.
I can't say I understood all of it,
but it was well worth the drive.
>> David Ossman: That's right.
>> Well, while I'm
thinking about it.
Getting back to bozos, why does the
porridge bird lay his egg in the air
and how or who or where did
you come up with a question
like that or should I even ask?
>> David Ossman: It's another
Phil Proctor story, I'm afraid.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah.
This is what the book is about.
It's so weird.
The -- I had a girlfriend named
Angel, big beautiful Texas girl,
and she told me a story
of her childhood.
How when she was a little
girl in Austin, Texas,
she'd go out into her backyard and
she'd play with the leprechauns.
And this one -- that's
what she told me.
And this one day, this leprechaun
came out from behind a stump
or something and said why does the
porridge bird lay his egg in the air
and then laughed and ran away.
Well, she told me this
story and I thought,
well, that's a good question.
So I brought it to the table
and it became the virus
that was planted in the computer.
Now, I looked into Irish
mythology and I discovered
that there was a king who had
been deposed and who lived
in a cage living on
porridge for years
until he was -- he
regained the throne.
And well, that's good, you know?
But basically, the best answer
to why does the porridge bird
lay his eggs in the air is
that we've killed all the trees.
Right?
>> David Ossman: That's one.
>> Phil Proctor: That's one.
>> David Ossman: That's possible.
>> Phil Proctor: But
it's a Zen question.
you know? Zen what?
Birdman and Radio Fiazi
[phonetic] created the Oz button,
which had four positions.
Remember?
>> David Ossman: Yes.
It was Oz or you could turn it
one way around and it would be no.
Or you could turn it the
other way and it would be Zo.
>> Phil Proctor: And you could
turn it the other way and it was --
>> David Ossman: Well,
it was Oz, No, Zo --
>> Phil Proctor: And what?
>> On.
>> David Ossman: On.
>> Phil Proctor: On.
Oh, yeah. How could
I forget that one?
On. And along with that in
the love-in kit that he sold,
there was a draft card, Mexican
air force, upon -- what was it?
Upon delivery, burn it?
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
It was Mexican Free Air Force.
>> Phil Proctor: Mexican Free Air
Force draft card or something.
Anyway.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
Peter had --
>> Phil Proctor: He
created the first love-in.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
The first love-in was Peter Bergman.
He invented the name.
>> Phil Proctor: At Elysian Field.
>> David Ossman: The whole thing
was at Elysian Park in Los Angeles
on Easter Sunday night, 1967.
>> Phil Proctor: Thousands
of people.
>> David Ossman: We were there.
>> Phil Proctor: Thousands
of people.
>> David Ossman: 17,000
people showed up.
>> Phil Proctor: It's amazing.
>> David Ossman: Something
like that.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah.
He was a power all right
and the best straight man
the world has ever seen.
Any other questions?
>> David Ossman: One more.
>> Yeah. This one, I
hope I get this right.
It occurred to me coming
here tonight
that what the heck are you
guys that you are what you are?
And it dawned on me it's
somewhere between --
there's nothing in comedy.
I was trying to figure out who is
doing this and I haven't seen it.
It's something more like --
and the word is overused --
ensemble that you guys
have stock characters,
but they move into places with
reckless abandon and then --
and yet, there's a through-line
and you do it as did it.
I mean, the four of you as a group.
Where is that now?
>> Phil Proctor: Well,
I guess Saturday Night
Live is the -- but no.
There's no -- nobody's ever done --
>> David Ossman: No.
Nobody really did what we did.
I mean --
>> Phil Proctor: Or has done.
>> David Ossman: Or
has done it since.
It was the magic, the chemistry.
That was a big part of it.
The fact that we had the
use of the Columbia studios
and they didn't censor us
and didn't care what we did.
They just put it out.
It's another rock and roll record.
They didn't know.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Phil Proctor: There
were two wonderful things.
First of all, a guy named John
McClure, producer at Columbia,
he was the one that signed
us to a spoken arts contract
after they were going to dump us.
Because he said these guys
are creating something new
and wonderful.
And that gave us unlimited
studio time for a reduced royalty
and it was well worth it because
we could do all this complex work
together and write and go into
the study and then go write again.
And that was one thing and then --
what was the other
thing you mentioned?
There's another factor in it.
Well, first of all, we
were our own producers.
Oh, I know what it was.
Records were basically uncensored.
I mean, you were playing
a record like ours --
>> David Ossman: And
that was the point.
>> Phil Proctor: You play it in
the privacy of your own home.
>> David Ossman: We were
talking directly to you.
>> Phil Proctor: Yeah.
>> David Ossman: We were uncensored.
>> Phil Proctor: You
played it at home.
We weren't writing it for a media
platform, for radio or television
or -- it was a private platform
that you could carry into your home,
share with other friends if you
liked it, and that was, I think,
the reason why it was -- we were
called underground comedians.
It was slightly subversive
in that regard.
But we were free to write
and speak uncensored.
>> David Ossman: And no one really
had that opportunity until now,
where, of course, you don't
have to have a studio.
You have it all in your watch.
>> Phil Proctor: Blog it.
Watch it.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: I'm listening
to something right now.
>> David Ossman: But as you
could see from that film,
it was fun, it was genuine work.
We worked really hard and then went
back after that and we wrote more
and we'd come back in the
studio never quite knowing
where we were going to go with it.
>> Phil Proctor: That's right.
>> David Ossman: And part of the
magic of the Firesign Theatre was
that Phil could come
up with something,
I could come up with
something, Peter could.
And it would change everything.
>> Phil Proctor: We got those
chaps together on the radio.
>> David Ossman: Yeah.
>> Phil Proctor: On
progressive radio.
Because we were able to improvise
together freely and we could bring
in stuff for other people.
David brought in Mark
Time [assumed spelling]
as a little skit for us to do.
And we just all dove right in.
We worked with an engineer
named Early Jive who used
to drop sound effects in on us.
Unexpected sound effects that
we'd also have to respond to.
Very unique.
Nobody else ever had
the opportunities we had
and that's why I don't
think anybody else was able
to follow the path that we followed.
>> David Ossman: Right place,
right time, and we love you.
Thank you.
>> Phil Proctor: Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Phil Proctor.
David Ossman, the Firesign Theatre.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.